what do you think would happen if he
invited an individual had been living on
the street for many years had mental
health issues unearth an alcoholic to
move directly from the street into
housing we'd heard this is being done in
New York City and we wondered and was
called the housing first model and we
wondered if it would work in Utah so to
make that determination we decided to
create a pilot and kita was one of the
seventeen chronically homeless
individuals we included in this pilot
she had been on the street for 20-plus
years had mental health and was a severe
alcoholic the first night in her
apartment she put her blinds on the bed
and slept on the floor the next three
nights she slept out by the dumpster
near the apartment building with the aid
of her case manager she moved back into
her apartment but continued to sleep on
the floor for several nights it took
over two weeks for her to develop enough
trust and confidence that this apartment
was hers and would not be taken away
from her before she starts sleeping in
the bed homeless is a continuing
challenge for many cities throughout her
country our homeless population falls
into three major categories those that
are temporarily homeless about 75% those
that are episodically homeless about 10%
and those that are chronically homeless
about 15% chronic homelessness as
defined as an unaccompanied adult who
has been continuously homeless for a
year or more or more than five four
times homeless in three years that
totals 365 days this small 15% of a
homeless population can consume 50 to 60
percent of the homeless resources
available in a community in addition
they can cost the community
20,000 to $45,000 a year per person and
emergency services costs
such as EMT runs emergency room visits
as many of you will be aware addictions
interactions of the police jail time
simply put this small population cost a
lot based on this reality the US
government began an initiative in 2003
inviting states and cities and counties
to develop a plan to end chronic
homelessness in a 10-year period the
state of Utah accepted this invitation
and I was asked to lead this effort in
2005 we approved a ten year plan and ten
years later in 2015 we reported a
reduction in our chronic homeless
population of 91% statewide that's
amazing
when I began this process and we began
this process I realized that I had a
limited understanding of homelessness
and the factors that impacted it that I
needed a fur team a fairly major change
in my belief and my thinking because I
had been raised with the theory of
rugged individualism and pull yourself
up by the bootstraps that plus we came
from being raised on her family's cattle
ranch in a small town in the western
desert of Utah on the ranch you learn
nothing takes priority over caring for
the cattle something always needs fixing
and most importantly hard work makes the
world right as through that lens that I
would see homeless people when I was a
teenager a family we'd gone to Salt Lake
City and I would see these homeless
people hobos would call them then
sitting around on the street and I would
think you lazy bums
get a job pull yourself up by the
bootstraps after high school I left the
ranch graduated from college went to
work for Ford Motor Company for several
years mm-hmm then got a job at the
Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints and moved back to Salt Lake City
during that employment I had the
opportunity to be loaned out to the
state's largest homeless shelter to
assist them in developing
and improving their financial and
management capabilities while there I
became aware of a new approach to
dealing with homeless individuals and
drug addicts it was called the harm
reduction model and it consisted of
passing out clean needles and condoms
and I thought now that is one stupid
idea that's just when I encourage them
to continue that behavior just tell him
to stop
several years later read some of the
early ten year plans to end chronic
homeless is promoted by the federal
government so read through those plans I
thought this is unrealistic
you can't down homelessness there's too
many personal choices in factors beyond
our control my perspective changed
however when I attended a conference in
2003 where I learned the reason behind
the 10-year plan first was this small
population of the homeless group there
was 15 percent and were very expensive
that made sense for a conservative state
like Utah second insight was learning
about this housing first or low barrier
housing there have been an agency in New
York City that had been inviting
mentally ill homeless individuals to
move directly from the street into
housing
they were also allowed to continue to
use drugs and to drink just like we can
in their homes they were in addition
offered services not required to use
them by on-site case managers to assist
them to adjust to the new living
arrangements and to stabilize their
lives they were using the harm reduction
model and despite my initial low
expectations about hearing about this
model they were having an astonishing
rate of 85% worstest percent were still
housed after 12 months the third insight
was the importance of developing a
trusting relationship because of the
abuse these individuals have had
throughout most of their life they
hardly trust anybody and the clean need
and condoms and low barrier housing was
a means to begin to develop a
relationship of trust vital so as I flew
home from this conference sitting in the
plane looking out the window I realized
my understanding and perspective about
homeless was shifting as I stared out
that window this very strong feeling and
thought came to me that if there's any
state in the Union that could end a
chronic homelessness it was the state of
Utah because there's an underlying
feeling and desire and willingness to
collaborate to serve our neighbors
including those who are homeless a new
vision was becoming clear to me how this
could be done
now those of us attended the conference
that how these models work in Utah we
only got back home there are many said
yeah those aren't going to work they
won't succeed here but there was however
an affordable housing organization who
is willing to build our first 100 units
but they had concerns about having 100
chronically homeless people in one
location to address that concern we
decided to create a pilot to test that
idea while we built the first 100 units
and we'd use existing units scattered
throughout Salt Lake City
then we debated okay should we select
fairly high functioning homeless persons
or the most challenging ones we could
find this is where my background on the
ranch came into play back then my mother
cooked our meals and heated the water
for our weekly bath on a wood burning
and coal burning stove after chopping
wood for that stove all those years I'd
learned to chop the big end of the log
first one had the most energy we decided
to use the been dog on the blog post
approach and selected 17 of the most
challenging difficult chronically
homeless people we could find because we
knew we would learn the most from them
22 months later all 17 were still housed
including Keita who today 11 years later
is sleeping in her own bed and is sober
at the end of this pie that one of the
young case manager said we used to
debate up at our university classes
which theory of case management was the
most effective now our theory of case
management is anything necessary to keep
them housed we became believers and
built hundreds of units over those next
10 years leading to the reduction of a
statewide chronic homeless population of
91% now who are homeless people many
people just want them to go away to
disappear not disrupt their lives
through this 10-year 11-year process I
gained many insights of why people
become homeless one of those insights
came to me a few years ago when I was
visiting with their medical outreach
team these are frontline workers that go
out and visit the street homeless and
the prostitutes to check on their
medical health one of the team members
mentioned that eight of the prostitutes
had given birth to 31 children that had
become Ward's of the state and they also
shared the some of the pimps with their
husbands and worse yet their parents
these prostitutes in the late teens 20s
early 30s were expected to earn enough
money to support a day to support
$100.00 day heroin addiction though
living expenses and their pimp and with
unprotected sex they were paid more and
predictably this would lead to a
pregnancy children born under these
circumstances many time end up becoming
homeless and it's not helpful to look at
those born into those circumstances or a
parent that makes the child a drug
addict at age 7 our generation of babies
born with a drug addiction and not feel
some despair for me I believe every
person is
value no matter who you are and it's not
helpful to look at somebody with this
start in life and blame them for where
they are no one grows up saying my goal
in life is to become homeless and that's
the beauty of the harm reduction and
housing first model it recognizes the
complexities of the different factors
that can shape a human life
these models meet people where they are
not where we are or where we think they
should be the pilot we did with their 17
taught us many lessons when people have
been living on the street for many years
moving back into housing requires lots
of things to learn and Donald taught us
some of these transition lessons his
case manager asked him why I had not
turned up the heat in his cold apartment
Donal said how do you do that he was
shown how to use a thermostat the case
manager also observed that he was
heating the beans in the can on the
stove like he had done over the
campfires for many years he was shown
how to use pots and pans we also learned
that he had his sister they had not seen
in 25 years who thought he was dead she
was happy to learn otherwise and they
were soon reconnected hundreds of people
like Keita and Donald are now housed and
reconnecting with their families and
also many of our communities are
incurring fewer emergency services cost
I have learned over and over again that
when you listen to somebody's story with
an open heart walk in their shoes with
them you can't help but love and care
for them and want to serve them
this is what why I'm committed to
continue to bring hope and support to
homeless citizens who I consider to me
might to be my brothers and sisters
thank you
[Applause]